imposter phenomenon is quite strong
among perfectionists but you look around
and see people are doing so much better
than you or how you think you're doing
so much better than you and you think
inside I have to prove every day I'm
good enough now for some people
Perfection or perfectionism is a trait
to strive for for most of us if you
listen to this podcast you're probably
Vaguely Familiar with the personal
development world and you probably know
that perfectionism is actually not a
very good thing and tends to hold us
back in life more than it actually helps
us and so today's episode is very
exciting because I'm joined by Thomas
current who's actually an assistant
professor at the London School of
economics and Thomas has recently
written a book called The Perfection
trap the power of good enough in a world
that always wants more success is a
bottomless pit it depletes Us in its
Pursuit and just like the Horizon it
keeps slipping away the further we get
to it this is how perfectionism operates
within the mindset of people and so of
course you know when things don't go
well we're going to turn on ourselves
because we weren't perfect in that
moment he has written for the Harvard
Business Review he was featured in new
scientists and his work has been covered
in also of Publications including the
guardian and the Telegraph and the Wall
Street Journal he kind of talks about
what we as individuals can do once we
know that perfectionism is kind of bad
to resist the trappings of society that
encourages us to constantly strive for
more and strive to constantly be perfect
you are a human being you exist so you
are enough and I think that's the most
important lesson to take through life
something to remember all the time when
things go well things don't go quite so
well it's okay you're human we fail you
are enough
welcome to the show thank you so much
for coming on thank you you are the
author of this fantastic book The
Perfection trap and in this episode I
thought we'd talk about all things
perfectionism because I wonder if we can
get started with uh a definition so what
is perfectionism so perfectionism is
really a world view I suppose the the
way we see and interpret the world and
our interactions with other people
um a lot of people think that it's a
very active optimistic High striving uh
excessively
um uh high goals and standards that we
hold for ourselves but actually that's
only part of the story because
perfectionists do have excessive
standards but it comes from a place of
deficit so it comes in this place where
I'm not good enough I'm not perfect
enough and therefore I must have these
high standards for myself to prove to
other people that I'm worth something
that I'm perfect then I'm Flawless
um and so really for me if you want to
get at the number perfectionism it's
really about that deficit thinking oh
interesting
um and one of the things you say in the
book is about how we've misunderstood
the root cause of perfectionism I wonder
if you can you can talk a little about
that or what have we misunderstood about
what causes perfectionism
I think the main thing is around where
it comes from and I think a lot of us
think that this is kind of a hard-wired
personality trait that we're kind of
born with or whether we just possess
um and that there's very little that we
could do about it it's kind of part of
our psychology and what I tried to do in
the book is is kind of probe that a
little bit and look at the data and we
know that about 30 to 40 of
perfectionism is genetic so that's to
say heritage so very little we can do
about it we kind of just born of it but
30 40 certainly is a lot for the
environment to explain
and my I guess exploration of
perfectionism is a cultural trait and a
uh something that's kind of socially
learned has has taught me that there are
many factors outside of us that kind of
weigh on our need to be perfect weigh on
that deficit thinking the world around
us radiates Perfection the world around
us tells us that there's always more to
do there's always bigger better we can
be fitter stronger more attractive and
as a consequence it isn't only a genetic
psychology psychological personality
trait but it also has a very strong
cultural influence and that's why in the
book I've described as a cultural
phenomenon so how how do we measure
perfectionism and I guess I'm kind of
asking in two senses firstly
in the studies how is perfectionism
measured and secondly how would someone
listening or watching this but like how
how might I identify whether I'm
struggling with perfectionism for
example so
academically to measure things and what
we've done over many decades is listen
to perfectionistic people tell us what
perfectionism is what are the main
characteristics or the main thought
process what are the main behaviors and
we kind of condensed all that
information into a set of items that we
can measure perfectionism on a scale so
you can say I strive to be perfect for
instance and how much do you agree with
that statement some people might agree a
lot some people might disagree some
people are kind of in the middle and so
in order to take a metric or a measure
perfectionism we kind of ask a string of
these kind of questions we aggregate
them and we see where people sit on that
spectrum and that's kind of typical to
most personality traits so it isn't just
perfection it's measure like that
conscientiousness extroversion
neuroticism all of these big personality
traits all measured in the same way and
that's one of the reasons again where I
talk about in the book perfectionism is
not kind of a black or white it's not I
am a perfectionist or you aren't a
perfectionist but it's really you know
where we sit on the perfectionism
Spectrum some of us will be more
perfectionistic on that Spectrum some
will be a little less most will be in
the middle and the big contribution I
think of my work and also I've updated
this data for the book is showing that
that middle bit of the Perfection
Spectrum where most of us sit is slowly
creeping upwards and we're seeing
growing levels of perfectionism over
time particularly among young people so
that's how we measure oh okay why is
perfectionism bad or potentially bad
perfectionism is is bad because of this
this idea that there's there's very it's
rooted in deficit and a lot of the
traits that it's confused with things
like meticulousness conscientiousness
diligence perseverance all of these are
great things but they're not
perfectionism these things include high
standards and they include striving for
really good results in what we do
but then don't come from a place of
deficit and that's what differentiates
those things from perfectionism
perfectionism very much comes from I'm
not good enough I'm not perfect enough
and I have to prove to myself and other
people that I am
um and when you start there you can
begin to unpack why perfectionism can be
really damaging so think about it it
comes from a place of deficit it's the
sense that I must move through the world
proving to other people that I'm good
enough so in order to do that I must
Excel I must be perfect I must have high
standards okay but what we're doing is
we're setting ourselves up for failure
because those excessive standards are
too high so what we find ourselves in
situations where we're not meeting those
standards we feel like we're failing we
feel like we're looking like a failure
to other people so we feel anxious our
self-esteem plummets and in order to
overcome those feelings and sort of
overcompensate we strive for even higher
standards which means we fail more which
means we feel more anxious more lower
self self-esteem and you can begin to
see how perfectionism really starts to
uh become a negative downward spiral
that gets entrenched and and accelerates
the more we overcompensate and the more
we encounter setbacks and failures so so
that's why perfectionism is particularly
damaging because it triggers this spiral
of self-defeat uh that can be really
difficult for people okay so uh and so
what I'll be right in saying that the
difference between healthy striving and
unhealthy perfectionism is what the root
cause is and we're saying that the root
cause is a sense of deficit a sense of I
am not enough therefore I must strive
for more absolutely in the unhealthy
category absolutely and and that's the
that's the difference between
perfectionism and these other traits
right because these other traits come
from a very active optimistic sense of I
want to improve I want to get better I
want to do the best I can do
but importantly I can let things go so
if I don't quite make that high standard
I'm able to take what's there to be
learned and move forward unfortunately
perfectionists have a real difficulty in
accepting that sometimes we just don't
improve or sometimes we go sideways or
sometimes we even regress and those
things are really catastrophic for the
perfectionist because it's really
difficult for them to reconcile those
feelings without over generalizing them
to the self right there must be
something wrong with me I haven't
succeeded in this case so therefore I'm
flawed and I'm irredeemable you know I'm
I'm kind of you know there's kind of a
very self-critical self-loathing mindset
that's that's a creep in for the
perfectionist so that's that's the core
difference yeah it reminds me of a few
friends I had at University who you know
the way they would approach studying for
exams is a constant striving to avoid
failure because you know in medical
school the whole like oh if I fail I you
know I was right about myself I knew I
did I didn't belong in Cambridge Medical
School I knew that I I you know I I knew
I wasn't good enough to be a doctor and
this is proof therefore I must strive to
not fail and then other and then other
of my friends including me would kind of
treat it as a bit of a game a bit of
competition it's like oh you know it's
like it's like playing a board game with
friends like oh you know what'd you get
on that exam but for those people who
were like the anti-failure mode asking
on asking that question of what did you
get on on that exam was like oh my God
like you know let's not talk about it
it's the worst thing ever like does that
Vibe with your experience of
perfectionism absolutely and I see all
the time in universities there's so many
students have a lot of trouble these
days accepting that they might not get
as good or great as they thought they
were going to get and they're really
averse to even the slightest bit of
critical feedback so we have to be
really careful and I think that's really
the indicative of this kind of
perfectionism that's beginning to take
over among young people where they're
really fearing the consequences of
failures because they're told failures
can be catastrophic particularly like
for your future life chances so of
course they've kind of develop this need
to excel at all times and even like uh
even a objectively high grade can feel
disappointing to the perfectionist uh
because as I say it's this kind of idea
that it's never quite enough the better
I'm due the better the better I do the
better I'm expected to do and there's
always this kind of churning of high and
excessive expectations that is really
difficult to reconcile with reality yeah
so you said earlier that um
perfectionism is about 30 to 40 genetic
uh what what does that mean and how do
we know
okay so about 30 to 40 of perfectionism
is genetic and we know that because
classic twin studies where we compare
identical non-identical twins against
adopted siblings and we look at the
similarities in their traits about 30 to
40 percent of personality and
self-oriented and socially prescribed
perfectionism these are aspects of
perfectionism measured in these studies
uh are genetically Heritage us to say
that they come from factors to do with
genes
um but as I mentioned earlier
that still leaves a lot for the
environment to explain so perfectionism
is very much a nature
but it's also there's a lot of nurture
in there too and what other personality
traits does perfectionism tend to
correlate with
so it correlates very strongly with
neuroticism uh so perfectionists tend to
be highly neurotic there is a
correlation what is neuroticism for
people who might not be familiar with
neuroticism is a personality trait uh
which essentially is rooted in anxiety
uh it's a sense of worry and rumination
about how we
um or how we're doing or how we're
appearing relative to other people and
and people who who are neurotic tend to
be very unsettled irritable anxious so
we see very high correlation between
perfectionism and neuroticism but
there's also interestingly a correlation
with information some conscientiousness
which is a which is a sort of rooted in
very hard work diligence perseverance to
tasks
um so there's this kind of really yin
and yang I suppose with perfectionism
when it comes to other personality Trace
there's some really good things that it
correlates with but it can also
correlate some really negative things
and so this this is why Perfection is
such a fascinating uh personality trait
because it has these kind of two sides
which make it really interesting and are
there any group differences like gender
or sex differences race differences even
between her perfectionism plays out
amongst like large groups of people yeah
it's a really good question
and it's one of I'm really challenging
to answer because the research that I've
done has looked at over 40 000 young
people
and um let's take gender differences
first because a lot of people would
think you know this is something that's
perhaps a little bit higher in in women
than it is in men
um but the data doesn't seem to bear
that out and that's really surprising
for us and surprising for other people
that I talked to so when we take these
40 000 people and we try to explain
levels of perfectionism based on the
number of females in a sample we don't
find anything there's no difference and
so that's really fascinating that men
and women tend to score relatively
similar on aspects of perfectionism now
that's not to say that women aren't
exposed to environments that trigger
perfectionism into a greater degree
that's not to say that the society we
live in still has
um impossible or expectations or puts
high in excessive expectations on women
more so than it doesn't matter I think
we can have that discussion and I think
that there would be a lot of validity to
that claim however in terms of levels we
don't see a great deal of difference
to your ethnicity question we just don't
have the data sadly but I we do have
some data that shows some interesting
cross-cultural differences for
perfectionism so in individualistic
cultures we tend to see perfectionism in
this kind of self-perfections that comes
from within this kind of sense that I
need to be perfect uh tends to be quite
High very dominant aspects of
perfectionism or any more collectivistic
cultures we tend to see perfectionism
this kind of social element affection
that kind of sense that everybody around
me expects me to be perfect well it
tends to be quite dominant and quite
high so there's an interesting cultural
differences in how perfectionism
expresses
um but gender is the one that we were
surprised by and we don't really find
anything there okay interesting um so
two points on that firstly on the gender
one that that surprises me because again
I could be wrong about this but I
thought that neuroticism and
conscientiousness are both slightly
skewed towards female and therefore if
perfectionism correlates with those
at least also anecdotally like most of
the people I know who would identify as
Perfection is tend to tend to be girls
but like yeah I guess you guys have
looked at 40 000 people with a worth of
data do you know we it surprised us too
it's it's one of those things where you
know our data set is probably the
biggest perfectionism data set uh that
we we have
um and you know when we threw that
variable into our aggression model we
were expecting to see something and it's
it's really striking that we didn't you
know these aren't perfect correlations
they probably share about 25 to 30
percent of variance which is quite
strong for you know psychological
variables but it certainly by no means
is a complete overlap between his
personality traits
so it doesn't necessarily uh it doesn't
necessarily Coral it suggest if one
correlate with the other that there
would also have higher higher mean
levels in the aggregate but yeah we were
surprised by that and it's one of those
findings that we're still we're still
looking at trying to figure out you know
what's happening there but as I say I
think there are contextual factors that
that make uh women a lot more vulnerable
to the impacts of perfectionism
but mean levels not so much hmm
I want to put a quick bookmark in that
contextual practice I think it would be
it would be definitely good to talk
about that yeah on on the cultural front
front so you said kind of
individualistic versus collectivist
cultures which generally means sort of
like West versus East I uh in a sort of
broad brush stroke yeah so I I would
would it be fair to say that for example
like before for example I know a lot of
people who are perfectionistic who are
from like India Pakistan kind of I'm
from Pakistan or my you know mates from
like whose families are Chinese there's
this whole vibe of like kind of the
Asian parent uh kind of phenotype of
Asian parent Asian families expects that
the child to be very very good at the
thing but then if I think of like my
white friends they tend not to have the
family expectation and yet they still
struggle with perfectionism so is that
what you you're kind of what you're
getting at with this sort of
collectivist versus individualistic kind
of vibe that's exactly what we're
getting at there there's a kind of an
independent interdependency in
collectivistic cultures whereby a lot of
the community and people around
individuals support
push maybe and that can impact on
people's psychology that's not quite
strong in individualistic cultures but
what is a bit stronger is this kind of
sense that it's up to you and only you
to make something of yourself yeah
anything of yourself right so there's
this kind of this kind of
self-perfectionism really comes through
a lot stronger in that kind of poetry
because it's really on the individual
and I think that's what's happening here
with those differences got it so we
mentioned um you know when it comes to
the gender differences there are
cultural or societal factors that maybe
affect some groups differently to others
we do have a sense of what those what
those are
okay that's a really big question to
unpack about in the book I try to
pinpoint several different areas of life
uh where perfectionism is really uh
dominant or where perfectionism is
accentuated lionized
um kind of Amplified and those those
core factors are within consumer culture
and this kind of idea that we we held
perpetually in a sense of deficit
because you know that's what helps us
consume and work and keeps the economy
spinning on its axis uh social media
which kind of takes that kind of model
and puts it into a social platform where
we're the content creators that create
this kind of Aura of discontent where
targeted ads can thrive I talk about uh
schools and colleges and how it's really
really uh tough right now for young
people to excel in school and college
because competition is so Fierce and
they need to be so much better than
their contemporaries just to get into
the elite colleges which allow them
access to the elite jobs and then of
course the workplace itself it's a
really insecure workplace right now for
young people it's completely changed
from when our parents were at work it's
all about the hustle all about the grind
it's all about the individual and that
can also uh perpetuate a sense of
perfectionism now within those those key
things of course there's going to be
certain subgroups that are much more
exposed than others that's got to say
that you know that they have it easier
because I think everybody in this world
is exposed to a lot of pressure these
days so I have to be clear there but
certainly I would say that there is a
lot of expectation on on young women
particularly when we look at things like
social media and the world of
advertising to kind of look and appear a
certain way to hold a certain
um personality speak and behave in
certain ways which I think men sometimes
get a bit of a pass on so I think there
is definitely expectations of women that
are greater than in many certain areas
particularly when it comes to image and
appearance and that still is the case
um and also some subgroups of people you
know people from lower down the social
class
um hierarchy you know they have to lift
themselves much further and than other
people and they start from way back and
that can create a sense of and a need to
Excel and overachieve in order to clear
those structural hurdles and of course
there's also still racial prejudices
discrimination that we see in society
and people from marginalized backgrounds
and underrepresented backgrounds also
have a really tough time kind of pushing
through those structural boundaries so
it's not just about class but it's also
about ethnic background where you know
that can also weigh on uh their sense
that they need to do so much better than
other people just to stay in the same
place and so those are those are you
know it was a big question to unpack but
I hope I was able to kind of give you a
good roadmap yeah no that's a good
roadmap and we'll put a link to the book
um and and your website and everything
else down in the show notes in the video
description wherever people happen to be
watching or listening to this if they
want to explore those areas more
um is there any data around uh sort of
adverse childhood experiences when you
mentioned the perfectionism stuff it
reminded me of some stuff that I've read
Around uh kids who feel uh
sort of abandoned by their parents when
they were younger Enders can often end
up becoming perfectionisty and like
they're oh okay cool I guess mummy
doesn't love me unless I do well in my
exam therefore let me continue to do
well in my exams is that is that is that
a thing that that the data shows as well
yeah so Ali I've got to be a bit careful
because I'm not a clinical psychologist
um so going into areas of sort of trauma
and early life experiences is not my
area however what I will say is I
studied a lot of clinical work in
perfectionism and we know that there is
a strong correlation between early life
trauma and later life perfectionism and
one of the big things there is this kind
of sense of Abandonment this kind of
sense that I wasn't I wasn't enough to
be approved of to to be loved
essentially and as a consequence that's
carried through into all the older
adulthood where we never really feel
like
um we uh are good enough we never really
feel like we deserve other people's love
and approval and as a consequence we
overcome say we tend to be very anxious
and this is why there can be some
significant you know mental health
problems that are associated
perfectionism that's rooted in that
early life distress but I would say that
that's probably a discussion for a
clinical psychologist rather than me as
a social psychologist
um but but the point is definitely valid
and there is a definite role for early
life experiences in later life
perfectionism
um we talked earlier about how
perfectionism is kind of on a spectrum
um or like a scale and it's not it's not
black or white
um and in the book you talk about your
grandfather as an example of potentially
like healthy striving rather than
perfectionism I wonder if you can tell
that story because I think it's quite
illustrative yes so my grandfather of
another era and I think this also is an
important factor in this conversation
because uh I think my my grandfather
would have a little bit of perfectionism
if he came through today but he came
through in an era where there wasn't
such demands there wasn't five star
reviews and everybody's providing
feedback on your work he was a carpenter
by the way so now he would of course
have a my Builder profile and everybody
would be reviewing his work and it would
be really a lot more uh pressurized and
I guess it was in his day however I used
to love going to watch my grandfather
build things he was a master Craftsman
he really had an eye for detail and he
created some just you know from the
vantage point of a child some amazing
things this and I think what's really
what I remember most about my
grandfather is that you know he didn't
have this kind of hanger but I have
about well is it good enough can I send
it out into the world he just made
everyday things that people needed and
he delivered those things to their new
homes didn't loiter for validation or a
five-star reviewer a fire Emoji he just
kind of left them there yeah and and and
that was and it was his vocation right
like that was his role he just wanted to
leave everyday things to know for other
people to use
and that is an extremely different way
to move about life to to go about your
working and professional life than the
way that perfectionists like me go about
it which is essentially oh goodness I
hope people like it I hope they give it
a good review I hope they're not going
to criticize me or find what I'm saying
um you know uh upsetting or whatever you
know because these are the doubts that
us Perfection is hard but all the time
my grandfather had no such Hang-Ups he
wanted to do well
and he wanted to prove to other people
of course that he was a good Craftsman
but if he didn't
do things perfectly if he left a bit of
varnish
or you know left a little screw just
jutting imperceptibly above the woods
he'd let those mistakes wash through him
as sure a sign of his fallibility is his
wrinkles are sciatica and I think that's
for me that's what differentiates a
conscientious
um a striver or a conscientious person
from a perfectionistic person this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
huel I've been a pain customer of heal
since my fifth year of medical school
since 2017 actually since before I
started my YouTube channel and I first
started using heal because my life was
pretty hectic I was juggling lots of
different things like medical school and
exams and trying to sort out publication
points for my future like doctor job
applications and alongside I was running
a business I was building an app and I
was trying to maintain some semblance of
a social life and so he actually came in
really handy for that if you haven't
heard of it it's basically a meal in a
shake that contains all of the
ingredients that are essential to thrive
it's got a perfect balance of protein
and carbs and fats and vitamins and
minerals and these days the heel black
edition is my absolute favorite comes in
nine flavors salted caramel is my
personal favorite and the heel black
edition is particularly good because it
is a higher protein version than the
huel original it was the original that I
was using back in 2017 but the Black
Edition came out a few years ago changed
the game because it's 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get Hench and so I'm keeping an eye on
like my protein intake and it's so nice
that I can get that high protein hit as
the first thing in the morning heel is
also very affordable it comes out to one
pound 68 per meal for a 400 calorie meal
which is actually way cheaper than most
of the other options on the market and
certainly way cheaper than other you
know even Standalone protein shakes like
I said I've been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. my friends literally make
fun of me as to how much fuel I have in
the house and they're like what you have
all this healed I'm like yeah it's
actually so good so if you're interested
in signing up for heal then head over to
heal.com forward slash Deep dive and if
you use that URL a it helps us out
because then they're Keen to sponsor
more episodes but B you get a completely
free t-shirt and a free Shaker with your
order so that is hopefully an incentive
to use hewell.com forward slash deep
dive and actually I interviewed the
founder of huel Julian Hearn on this
very podcast in the very first season so
you can check out that episode if you
like it's got rave reviews really good
episode all about starting and growing a
business so anyway thank you so much
heal for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to twenty
thousand pounds and it resets every
April and then all that money can grow
and it's completely tax-free for the
rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on trading
212. so if you haven't yet filled up
your eyes allowance or at least put some
money into your Isa for this year that
might be a good step forward also very
excitingly there's a new feature that
they've added to the app which is a
daily interest on your uninvested cash
these interest rates may go up or down
over time as the economic environment
changes but the cool thing is that you
get paid out every single day if you're
into that sort of thing the app also
lets you Auto invest which is a great
thing because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started with investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali it will
give you a totally free share worth up
to 100 pounds it's available on iPhone
and Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode you mentioned your your
perfectionist yourself yes what sort of
perfectionist trades do you see in
yourself
uh worry about what other people think
worry about uh whether I'm doing enough
uh worry about my place and whether I
belong uh imposter phenomenon is quite
strong among perfectionists particularly
perfectionists that have come from you
know I've come from a working class
background into a middle class world and
you often doubt yourself you wonder if
you deserve to be there you wonder if
your works of a certain standard you
look around and see people who are doing
so much better than you or how you think
you're doing so much better than you and
you and you think inside I have to prove
every day that I'm good enough that I
deserve to be here and that I'm trying
to disguise this kind of flawed and
inadequate person that I think I am
inside now I'm doing so much better now
this was something that consumes me in
my 20s and led to quite significant
mental health problems which is prom
what prompted me to really take an
interest in this topic I'm able to let
things go now I'm able to try to strive
a bit more like my grandfather did his
driving and kind of let things go and
accept that not everybody's going to be
happy with what you say and not
everybody's gonna think that your work
is amazing and that's okay that you know
sometimes you're gonna slip up and do a
really bad lecture or answer a question
in a way that's sub-optimal and also
that's okay so I'm learning I'm learning
uh to get on top of my perfectionism but
nevertheless it's certainly something
that I I definitely suffer with
so what strategies have you used to get
better at this over the last I'd say
like say 10 years
the biggest one for me is to just let
life happen
and I think there's a real impulse in
this culture to happen in the world as
if everything and all around us can be
mastered can be perfected
um Can it in some way be overcome
sometimes for no good reason we fail
sometimes things happen to us that we
have no control over
and accepting that fact is really the
first big step in breaking through
perfectionism because then you are ready
and prepared that for for to have a sort
of goal in your mind where you want to
go but you're kind of aware that this is
where I want to be but you know that the
journey to get there is not going to be
straightforward it's going to have
lots of headwinds lots of stumbling
blocks lots of setbacks things that you
can't control that you have to be very
agile in navigating that you have to
accept that
sometimes you're going to stand still
and go nowhere for a few months
sometimes you're even going to regress
you know you're going to think you've
mastered something and suddenly
something comes along that teaches you
actually you didn't know what you were
doing in the first place you have to
relearn these things and so life is
really a jagged path and instead of kind
of trying to meet every setback by
trying to force yourself forward and
avoid uh encountering those difficulties
putting things off procrastinating
worrying about what other people think
just allowing it allowing anxiety in
allowing the worrying and that just
sitting comfortably next to next to
situations and things aren't quite going
to plan
and keeping on going keeping on towards
that ultimate goal I think that for me
is the biggest the biggest difference
between how I used to think and how I
think now because it's so much more
psychologically liberating when you can
understand that things aren't going to
always go to plan and that's okay we can
sit with that
hmm yeah that seems to be a thing that I
mean almost every spiritual teaching
also goes towards that like you know if
even if we think of the ancient
philosophies like stoicism it seems like
all of these different ways of tackling
life uh end up on the conclusion of
allow things to happen as they are live
in the present moment don't live in the
past or in the future which causes
essentially sadness and anxiety worrying
about the future but if we can just
focus on what's within our control and
just keep going put one foot in front of
the other all of those cliches but they
I think those cliches are a cliche for a
reason because there's like universal
truth behind them yeah but also I think
they're almost too easy to dismiss
in the sense that if someone is
struggling with perfectionism they might
hear about I don't know epic tetuses
like dichotomy of control or whatever
and be like oh yeah of course I should
you know just do the you know you know
God grant me the serenity to accept that
that which I can cook I can't control
but it's a lot easier said than done
absolutely
um and it's easier for some people than
it is for others and let's be honest
about this a lot of self-help is
predicated on this notion that you know
um be more meditative positive thinking
caring for herself when things haven't
gone well these are all very Noble
things to advise but some people are in
situations where doing those things
being authentic letting things happen
it's a really difficult thing to do
because if you're poor and you let
things happen and things don't go well
the impact of that is can be
catastrophic I can be losing your
tendency it could be surviving on
minimum wage so that so you know I think
this is why I try to impress in the book
that this this idea of kind of letting
things go isn't created equally for some
people the consequences of that are far
more severe than other people and I
think we have to be really uh cognizant
as a society that yes there are
individual things that we can do that
are important but we also as a
collective have a responsibility to help
people become more Serene in the way
that they live allow things to happen
and and that the consequences of when
things go wrong be not as catastrophic
as sometimes they can be in today's
society so yes it's an individual's uh
issue that I think a lot you know that
we need to work on but also as a
collective things we can do Society too
so I just I think one of the things I'm
really Keen to caveat in this book is
not just go all in on this kind of
authenticity be vulnerable Show Yourself
allow things to happen without also
acknowledging that that's easier for
some people to notice for others yeah
that's a good point there's that there's
that classic thing that people say
around you know anxiety and things that
like oh you know it's you know
fundamentally rooted in fear the
amygdala was designed to you know save
us from getting more to buy a
saber-toothed tiger and was also in
caveman era designed to help us combat
social threats and now it's gone Haywire
because actually those same survival
mechanisms are no longer serving us but
I guess what we're saying is that
actually for some people they are
genuinely survival mechanisms if you
can't make rent and you end up on the
streets that is a survival mechanism it
really is compared to if your book does
not hit the New York Times bestseller
list and Only Hits the Sunday Times
whatever the hell whatever the hell
there's like there are different levels
of actually some things are threatening
people's survival and others aren't uh
in in as great a degree yeah I guess
either way you can't really whatever the
consequences you can only really control
what's under your control but it's it's
way easier said than done especially if
your survival is genuinely being
threatened absolutely and I think this
is really important for people to
recognize that you can acknowledge the
world needs to change you can want the
World to Change and you can also meet
the world where it is those two things
are not mutually exclusive and that's
our challenge uh for for us to accept
that you know we do live in a very
tilted economy lopsided economy
um and it is tough for a lot of people
and becoming tougher as we enter into a
cost of living crisis and and young
people in particular find it really
difficult to get on things like the
housing ladder and and uh start families
and all the rest of it I think it's
really really important that we can
recognize those issues we can we can
understand that they are impacting on
the way we feel particularly on the
perfectionistic thoughts and feelings
because we try to overcompensate for
those strong Natural Things by working
harder
want them to change but also allow
ourselves to meet the world where it is
let's setbacks in let those things wash
over us a little bit as frustrating and
you know anxiety provoking as they are
um and and live as you as you mentioned
with a little bit more contentment a
little bit more Serenity one two things
to change
maybe even agitating for that change but
also accepting where we are our life
circumstances
um
and I think that's for me that's the key
and that's that's what's helped me break
through my Perfections nice
um I want to tackle many more action
points because we have lots of action
points in the book uh but before we do
that I thought we'd touch on the
multi-dimensional model of perfectionism
so we kind of alluded to this a little
bit when talking about Asians versus
white people but like um what is the
multi-dimensional model of perfectionism
so the more dimensional model of
perfection is really an acknowledgment
that perfectionism is more than just
personal steps
so as I mentioned perfectionism really
starts with this kind of deficit
thinking
but that can be expressed in so many
different ways and over Decades of
talking to perfectionistic people we've
realized that perfectionism isn't just
about I need to be perfect and uh if I'm
not perfect I'm highly self-critical of
myself this is called self-oriented
perfectionism right self-winded
perfectionism comes from itself
and yes this is a very dominant aspect
of perfectionism particularly in
individualistic cultures but it's not
the only one
speaking to perfectionistic people that
we also find is a particularly
pernicious social route to perfectionism
too so the sense that perfectionistic
people tend to feel like the social
environment uh around them is highly
expectant of perfection and is very
judgmental and it's called socially
prescribed perfectionism so socially
prescribed Perfection some
perfectionists kind of hear very snide
remarks about them everywhere they go
they feel like people are judging them
highly and they and they're expected to
be perfect
and then there's a third aspect called
other interperfectionism which is kind
of perfectionism that's turned outwards
onto other people so I expect you to be
perfect and if you're not perfect then
I'm very judgmental and very harsh and
very punitive and these three aspects of
perfectionism are really what we
understand to be a multi-dimensional
model of perfectionism that isn't just
one thing like high standards high self
standards and striving but also has
social elements like social prescribed
and also other oriented and together
these are the three aspects of
perfectionism that I outline in the book
hmm
yeah okay so I'm just going to read out
a few um you know for people in um who
are watching or listening this is I
think one of the the multi-dimensional
perfectionism scales just to give people
a sense of these these three different
things so self-oriented perfectionism
and I guess as you're listening or
watching to this um and sort of have a
think about like
to what extent do you kind of agree or
disagree with these phrases as they
relate to you so self-oriented
perfectionism I must be perfect at the
things that matter to me if I screw up
or fall short I'm hard on myself I hold
myself to an exceptionally high standard
if I do not appear or perform perfectly
I feel a lot of guilt and shame and I
strive to be perfect and those are all
the self-oriented perfectionism things
we've got five things for socially
prescribed perfectionism when I slip up
or fall short people are right there
waiting to criticize me
everyone else is perfect and they're
judging me if I'm not perfect too those
close to me will accept nothing less
than perfection
people tend to get upset with me if I
don't do things perfectly and everybody
expects me to be perfect
and then we have other oriented
perfectionism I find it difficult to
tolerate substandard performances from
those around me
if people aren't trying their absolute
hardest I'll let them know everyone
should totally excel at things that are
important to them when someone close to
me screws up or falls short it's
important to call them out and I dislike
being surrounded by people who've got
low standards
um so we'll put this questionnaire in
the show notes and the video description
as well if you fancy whoever's listening
to this um sort of rating yourself on
these things
um the other oriented perfectionism one
I thought was interesting because I
would not have thought that that would
come under the definition of
perfectionism because that's more like
having high standards I guess or
perfectionistic standards for the people
around you
yes but you have to uh remember where it
comes from so I've ruined to
perfectionists uh are doing what Freud
would call projection so this sense that
you know I have a burning need to be
perfect and if I'm gonna haul myself
over hot coals to get there you are
gonna do it too because that's only fair
and so you tend to find that people high
in perfectionistic Tendencies can
sometimes uh Point those Tendencies out
it's not all the time you know not
everyone is enough orange perfectionist
a lot of people like myself wouldn't
dream of of imposing the standards I
place on myself but you tend you can
find that some people do and a good
example would be Steve Jobs is someone I
wrote about in the book who's clearly
and you know incredible uh entrepreneur
business person as you know one of the
most successful if not the most
successful uh in the in the world
um but you know he was a complicated man
at the same time and and uh
autobiographical accounts show that he
was a perfectionistic person expected
perfection in his own life expected
Perfection of himself but also
importantly expected Perfection of other
people and when they weren't up to his
standard he let them know
and and that is an example of someone
who has high standards themselves but
can sometimes turn them out onto other
people and that's why we we find
sometimes you know when perfectionistic
people
talk to us come into the uh you know
clinicals uh uh environment or even just
come into a research environment and
they tell us about their perfectionism
one of the things sometimes we see is
this kind of over into perfectionism
okay and do you find that those people
are also like
uh or tend to be perfectionistic in
themselves or can you have pure other
oriented perfectionism without actually
feeling the effect of it you're in in
internally really good question uh don't
touch on this book actually but let's go
into it because it is it is a it is a
very very interesting question
so the answer is it depends so what we
tend to see is those who've got high
levels of perfectionism
software into perfectionism fused with
or combined with high levels of other
oriented perfectionism right can can
demonstrate what we would consider to be
very really highly perfectionistic
tendencies that has an impact on them
and those around them and that can have
negative consequences for their social
relationships it can also have a
negative consequence for their own
mental health now there is a case that
we've looked at in the literature where
you can see these high standards divorce
from perfectionism but fused with
something called narcissism and so we
call this kind of narcissistic
perfectionism which is something that I
haven't touched on the book because I
think it's quite quite separate um to
the issues that I wanted to tackle but
nevertheless there's some really
interesting studies on this that I've
done myself where you tend to find over
into perfectionism doesn't come with
perfectionistic Tendencies but instead
comes to use with narcissism and so
these people have a sort of grandiose
view of themselves and therefore they
they uh almost kind of channel that
grandiosity into extra
they expect for other people and um and
that isn't necessary you know it doesn't
have the same uh interpersonal
consequence as to say psychological
consequences for the person themselves
but has significant and implications for
the people that these these uh
individuals interact with yeah because
um
it's a very very draining let's imagine
you had a narcissistic perfectionist
boss that would be a very draining way
to work that would be an extremely
difficult working environment trying to
navigate those Tendencies
um and so you can have it without
self-oriented perfectionism
um and it can be fused with narcissism
and just thinking back to all my
interactions with my team and thinking
oh have I but okay so what are the again
what's the what's the difference between
having high standards and being a
narcissistic perfectionist
is it just a matter of degree well let's
put it this way
the perfectionist doesn't believe the
bulletproof narrative they're trying to
construct for themselves deep down right
they feel like they're inefficient
they're flawed and they're not worth
anything and that's why they try to
project Perfection to prove to other
people and gain the validation and
approval of other people so that as kind
of props for their self-esteem which is
really low
narcissists are very different their
self-esteem is really high because they
believe the narrative the bulletproof
narrative that they're constructing for
themselves they actually take on that
image and think that they are
um the perfect worker boss that they you
know that they're projecting outside and
to other people that's the critical
difference between a perfectionist and a
narcissist
okay got it
um
in what way does perfectionism
contribute to lower I guess productivity
okay that's I love this question because
the answer is fascinating so you would
think wouldn't you the perfectionists
would succeed and that's kind of very uh
common uh Convention of wisdom I guess
in broader Society right the
perfectionists of these kind of really
high over Strivers and as a consequence
they succeed we know that there's
baggage we know that there's kind of
mental health problems that can coexist
with perfectionism but on the other hand
these these people are really high
Achievers and you know you can point to
the hyper perfectionist Serena Williams
Victoria Pendleton Steve Jobs Demi
Lovato you know all these people are
self-confessed Perfection made it to the
top of their professions clearly really
talented and high achieving and
therefore it must be the perfectionism
that propelled them there
when we look at the data however we find
no relationship between perfectionism
and performance and this is really
curious because they work so hard they
put everything into their activities and
yet they don't seem to perform any
better why is that well there's two
reasons one reason is that they work
hard but they work too hard so what you
tend to see is this kind of declining
and then diminishing returns to any unit
extra unit of input so they've worked at
the max and then beyond they sacrifice
rejuvenating activities like Diet sleep
good healthy behaviors I exercise for
instance we know they're rejuvenating we
know these things help with work
performance they don't do them they burn
out and we know the strong correlation
with infections in the burner so this is
kind of one of the reasons why
professionists struggle to perform
perhaps
to the to the extent that their effort
would suggest they should do but the
second reason is a really fascinating
reason and one that we've been really
Keen to look at in the lab and the
second reason is perfectionists find it
really tough when things start to go
wrong
so if you give perfectionist a task to
do you say look you should comfortably
achieve this outcome on this task and
you say go ahead and do it so we put
people in the lab that's and we use
sport because sports are really good
microcosm of sort of more competitive uh
Society more generally I would say okay
you should comfortably complete this
distance in this time on this cycling
task right so go away and do it we'll
get them to do it it went really really
hard and then at the end we tell them
unfortunately you didn't quite make the
target we set
and then we do something really naughty
we say try again
now the perfectionistic people
when they are given that failure
feedback feels so ashamed of that and
embarrassed of that failure
that they will do everything they
possibly can to avoid feeling those
things again so on the second trial what
we see is that effort drops off a cliff
because you can't fail at something you
didn't try so as soon as they encounter
situations of almost certain defeat
where they know putting everything of
themselves into it is not going to end
well they just withhold
now people or aren't particularly
perfectionistic do the complete opposite
when we tell them to do it again their
effort doesn't change if anything it
goes up slightly
and that is another reason why
perfectionists really struggle to
perform because it's fine when things
are going well but as soon as things
start to go wrong and there's a high
chance of failure they withdraw
themselves now that's in the lab how
does that look in real life well in real
life they procrastinate
they find anxiety-provoking situations
things that are really tough really hard
to get going they see the task ahead of
them they know it's going to be too
challenging and so the mental energy and
the anxiety that that's stirring up in
them is so Fierce that they'll just
completely hold the hold effort so
they'll stop doing things they'll
procrastinate they'll watch the latest
Netflix series they'll go and cook up
the latest tiktok recipe anything to
avoid facing the anxiety of doing a task
that needs to get done now of course
that helps it eases that anxiety for
that moment but in the end they're just
damaged by the passage of time and as a
consequence the work goes in late or
it's substandard or it's not as good as
it could have been because we're under
these time pressures because of the
withdrawn of procrastination that we're
engaging in which again is not conducive
to high performance
so it's a really really fascinating top
of this one and I wanted to cover a
separate chapter in the book because I
think it's really important that people
understand that yes perfectionism has a
kind of sense that it it's this you know
positive motivational Force but actually
when you dig deeper when you look closer
you tend to find that Perfections really
struggle to perform hmm
it's almost like a self-sabotaging
behavior right yeah exactly that is
exactly what it is perfectionist that
world-class self-saber charges
is this something that you struggled
with absolutely I mean you know my book
is two years overdue my editor was ready
to throttle me I think as a you know as
I was still tinkering with it at the you
know the day before is to go to press uh
you know we just can't help ourselves
because we just want things to be
perfect and we find it really
challenging psychologically for them not
to be so we Tinker we iterate we work
too hard we put things off
um we we kind of manage our anxiety in
sub-optimal ways and uh obviously a
better way to handle that would just be
to get things done to get things on a
page you know so idea that done is
better than perfect I know that and I
try as hard as I can to engage with that
Mantra but it's tough Technically when
you're putting a book out into the world
you know for everyone to read I mean
that's really that's a big thing yeah
they I know the feeling
um one of the things that
um my writing coach helped me realize
was I had a lot of
perfectionistic Tendencies when it came
to writing a book and I don't really
have those with making YouTube videos
even though a YouTube video might get a
million views which is more views than
my book is ever going to sell copies of
so like for some reason when it comes to
a YouTube video I feel more chill about
putting myself out there in that sense I
guess because I've made like 700 of them
at this point over the last six years
but the thought of a book oh my God a
book is a big deal yeah and my writing
coach was like why are you thinking that
a book is a big deal I was like I don't
know because it's in bookshops and it
was like why does that make it a big
deal and we kind of like went on this
line of questioning and I kind of
realized the reason a book is a big deal
is because it is more open to criticism
than a random video is because a random
video will be seen by people who already
like me and that's fine but a book might
be bought by someone who doesn't know
who I am doesn't know anything about me
and I can just imagine the Amazon
reviews this guy thinks he knows
anything about productivity what a
freaking [__] like how dare he suggested
that like blah blah blah and I can just
imagine reading those and knowing in my
in my mind that yeah
Haters Gonna Hate and you know this
person's just expressing a preference
and like it's all good water under the
bridge but in reality the the feeling of
like oh no my work is being criticized
and judged oh yeah it's some level it's
gonna you you can try to brush it off
but at some level it's always going to
impact you right and I think it's really
interesting what you say in terms of you
know you have a level of comfort with
the with the things that you know you do
well the things that you know uh attract
viewers that gain a lot of um attention
whereas with something that you're not
quite sure about yet because it's the
first time you've done it and you
haven't really tested it with with the
outside world that can be really like
psychologically that can be a real
challenge so I think it's it's you what
you're expressing there is you know what
I feel I think what most people feel and
isn't just you know about writing books
it's whenever we push ourselves out of
our comfort zone there's always that
trepidation and if you're
perfectionistic that trepidation is
going to be Amplified nice
so we spent
um some time talking about I guess uh
the misconceptions and the causes and
the kind of root causes of perfectionism
and we've hinted on one of the action
points that you found helpful which was
this thing of letting life wash over you
and being being okay with how things
turn out
I wonder if we can go over some more
action points so for someone listening
and watching this far who might Vibe
with perfectionism in their own life
what are some other things that we can
do to get over perfectionism or at least
reduce the impact that it might have on
us okay
so I think there's really
first of all first and foremost before
we do anything else I think it's really
important to appreciate web Perfection
is coming from and I want readers to
pick up my book and come away the sense
that this isn't your fault there are a
broader context to these feelings that
actually your society and economy is
designed structured organized to instill
a sense of deficiency because if you
didn't feel deficient if you felt
content you wouldn't consume you
wouldn't work and our economy would
quite quickly and abruptly spiral into a
recession at that point which is the
worst kind of depression recession a
demand driven a demand deficit driven
recession which would create all sorts
of uh Havoc so
this feeling of being not enough is
really fundamental to the way in which a
society is structured I really want
people to bear this in mind because I
think this takes a lot of power away
from that deficit thinking to understand
that okay this is the system working
this is a system working exceptionally
well perfectionism is really wise
proficient as evidence of the system
works that we have created
um uh a a situation and a culture in
which people feel compelled to consume
and work as hard as they possibly can in
order to prove themselves of worth in
this society and if we can understand
that if we can wrap our head around that
then that is the most important starting
point this is not your fault these
feelings have a broader context and it's
okay
now from there what can we do well I
talk about my book the fundamental role
of self-acceptance because I think
self-acceptance is really like taking
the sledgehammer to perfectionism and
underneath that broad philosophy as some
actionable things you can do and the
first is self-compassion
now we have to at all times treat
ourselves with kindness if you screw up
a presentation kindness if you didn't
get the grade you wanted in your
assessment
kindness okay if you went to work and
your annual review came back and it
wasn't quite as good as you're expecting
don't go out of that room with your boss
and berate yourself how could it be so
stupid what was I thinking why didn't I
put in more effort why didn't I work on
weekends or evenings or whatever to to
make sure that this didn't happen
kindness
it's okay it did my best I worked hard
nobody's perfect I made mistakes we're
human and to be human is to be imperfect
if we can learn to treat ourselves with
kindness at every every time something
goes wrong
we will instantly start to break down
those self-critical features of
perfectionism that make it such a
difficult personality trait to carry
around now that's not easy and it takes
time and practice you're not going to do
it straight away I still come out of my
lectures if I've done a bad job or I
think I've done a bad job and asked
myself what was I thinking but instantly
I'm turning that around I'm saying okay
you know it's one bad lecture out of
many many that I give it's not going to
impact my future career it's not as
catastrophic as you instantly think it
is it's just one bad day at the office
right the second thing is to challenge
our perfectionism in in important ways
so being yourself critical after
setbacks is crucial but also putting
ourselves in situations where we
encounter setbacks is also crucial
remember I talked about perfection you
can recoil from those situations it's
really really important to try to push
yourselves into them instead so if you
don't feel like one of your talents is
speaking for instance push yourself at
work to do a talk
go through the anxiety that that
engenders just sit with it let it wash
over you for a little bit and then go
out there and do it
and you will almost always find at the
end of that
talk that the impact or the feedback or
the consequence of it was not as
catastrophic as you thought it was going
to be look look it might not be a you
know a polished erudite speech that
maybe you see on a TED Talk it might not
be that but at the same time
it also is likely to have been an
experience where you've learned
something where you stood in front of
people and conquered that fear and tried
to push through and break through your
perfectionism those are really important
things to take away because those things
that you can learn that help you develop
that help you become more confident and
as and importantly how you break through
your perfectionism is by taking those
small steps out of your comfort zone so
challenging your perfectionism is is
really important try to do that as much
as you can and thirdly
and this is really important
always remember that whatever you do
failure is not humiliating it's
humanizing it's normal and natural to
fail in fact
we will fail way more than we will
succeed you have one success it's
followed by infinite amounts of failure
because failure is just regression to
the mean it's it's a it's an it's it's
an indication that we're moving in a
direction that we're learning that we're
developing and it's really important to
remember that failures part and parcel
of that process it's not humiliating
it's not something shameful that needs
to be
rehabilitated at all times it is just
what it is it's a part and parcel of
human growth human development
um and I think that's so so important we
need to change our relationship with
failure and remember that it's a very
humanizing part of the human condition
so those I think are the main three
things that I think
I would like readers to take away from
the book right we're going to take a
very quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is
brilliant.org brilliant has been a
supporter of my channel for the last
several years I've been using that
product for the last several years and
it's the best app I've ever found for
online courses in maths and science and
computer science the courses are really
fun and interactive and engaging and you
learn stuff and then you apply it with a
practical puzzle and you learn a bit
more and then you've applied a bit more
so it's generally a way more engaging
and interesting way of learning stuff
compared to how we might have been
taught in school for example my favorite
courses are brilliant are the computer
science courses so back when I was
applying to med school I was actually
torn between medicine and computer
science and I went for medicine in the
end which I don't regret but there was
always a part of me that really wanted
to understand how computer science works
and so when I started taking the
computer science courses on brilliant it
really helped me understand like at a
deep level what the deal is with the
basics of computer science like they've
got a fantastic course introduction to
algorithms they've got a whole course on
cryptocurrencies which is all about how
cryptocurrencies actually work and how
the kind of sha-256 encryption works and
it teaches the topic of cryptography and
Security in a really fun and engaging
way which is way better than any other
explanation I found on the internet
anyway if any of that stands up your
street and you would like to level up
your knowledge and your thinking in
terms of maths or science or computer
science then do head over to
brilliant.org forward slash Deep dive
and the first 200 people to use that
link which is also in the video
description and in the show notes we'll
get 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
and let's get right back to the podcast
to the point about self-compassion uh a
book that I've recently reread
um in the last week is called love
yourself like your life depends on it by
a guy called Kamal ravacan and I read it
a few years ago and I was like ah ah
it's a bit woo it's a bit like you know
hand wavy and then I read it again last
week I was like oh okay like this is
actually actually really solid and one
of the exercises you know this guy talks
about you know he was a successful like
investor startup guy and I had a lot of
struggles with mental health and
perfectionism and depression and things
and one very actionable strategy that he
found really helpful is just you know
throughout the day
reminding himself to take to take a few
breaths and when breathing in just
literally telling himself I love myself
and I've been trying this for the last
few days where I'm just like you know as
I'm walking walking down and walking
towards the car while listening to an
audiobook at 3x speed on my airpods just
like looking up taking a breath and just
sort of saying to myself internally I
love myself and then breathing out and
the way he describes it as like imagine
taking a deep breath and imagine like
light from above coming into your system
and then as you breathe out that light
is going into the areas of your body
where it most needs to go
and I was like nah come on come on this
is this is bollocks and I tried it uh I
was like oh I I actually do just feel
better and there's something about that
um that's profoundly you know like just
just that active Act of self-compassion
because the way you know as as you would
know
if we the the way that we operate in
life is mostly sort of system one mostly
uh Instinct based on
having a thought repeatedly and then
that thought gets uh solidified and the
grooves form in our mind and so it
becomes way easier to have that thought
and so if the thought going through our
mind is I'm not worthy I'm not good
enough I'm a failure and we repeat those
often enough those become the default
paths through the through the forest of
our mind whereas if we can just tell
ourselves a couple of times a day I love
myself and that thought then becomes a
default that just changes the way that
we approach almost every situation in
life so I've been finding that really
powerful over the last few days I think
it's so powerful it's it's just
as I said it's like taking a
sledgehammed into perfectionism you know
you Perfection the perfectionists will
always find ways that they didn't
succeed or they didn't do something
perfectly or they or there was always
some [__] in the Armory that they will
find
even if you've done something
exceptionally well in fact you know even
objectively high levels of achievement
to perfectionists aren't enough because
success is a bottomless pit it depletes
Us in its Pursuit and just like the
Horizon it keeps slipping away the
further we get to it this is how
perfectionism operates with the mindset
of people and so of course you know when
things don't go well we're going to turn
on ourselves because we weren't perfect
in that moment and exactly what you've
just said if we can turn that or reframe
those thoughts from instantly turning on
ourselves to instantly telling ourselves
it's okay that you are enough that
actually you know there's a sense of
love and appreciation for ourselves in
this moment how we are right now
it's that's so powerful
one of the places I'm trying to get to
and I'm I'm not here yet but it seems
like a lot of more spiritually
enlightened people are here is
instead so like what one level is like
you fail at something and you're like oh
I'm a failure I'm a terrible person the
next level is you fail at something and
you're like that's fine you know it was
just a bad day at the office but then it
feels like the next level up is almost
not even registering it as a failure
because a failure or even a success is a
value judgment it's a story that we tell
ourselves about the flow of life and if
we can just surrender to the flow of
life and allow things to be as they are
and not give it to the value definitely
the value judgment of this was good or
this was bad oh that would be such a
freeing way to live right I'm not there
yet but there's like you know a path to
work towards it would but the way
Society is at the moment but uh you'll
quickly be let know if it wasn't good
particularly the higher you go right
like if you're a content creator like
yourself you know if you put out
something that isn't quite of the
standard of the other videos people are
going to be right there to let you know
and it's so it's one thing to to say
okay you know there's a value judgment
of things not going quite as as well as
you want but there's also
uh having to kind of do that kind of
thought process in a in a society in a
world particularly you know online world
where you'll be reminded very quickly
yeah so that's a challenge yeah that's
the challenge exactly yeah like one I
sometimes think like when it when it
comes to kind of uh negative comments on
the internet
one very reasonable approach is to just
not read them um
but I I I I I'd like to get to the point
where I can read them and they'll just
watch over me and it's just like it's a
spiritual training almost it's train
training of the mind but you know so
I will uh let the audience know what I
ever get if I ever get there but I don't
think it's gonna happen anytime soon
um one thing that you say in the book is
um to give up a status position as like
us an actionable thing what do you mean
by that
one of the things that I think is really
challenging right now and I I dedicated
chapter to this is uh is the
omnipresence of consumer culture
um and I talk about my own experiences
in the book growing up
um poor and going to school and seeing
all around me people who have the best
trainers the newest phones and as you as
we got into the sixth form you know the
fact these kind of new cars and this
kind of excess that you'd see that was
kind of ways of marking people's States
and of course you know all of those kids
were the kids at the schoolyard cred you
know they're the people that people
looked up to because consumer culture
and cultures of success teach us to be
embarrassed about any part of our lives
that don't match up like there's
something wrong with you if you don't
have these things
and I think one of the the key lessons
really is that I definitely got myself
wrapped up in that uh I I definitely
looked at other people around me and
just yearned wanted craved for the
things that they had and it was really
psychologically problematic and I
started to try to plug those holes and
material things when I was in my twin
does Easter by a lot of you know the
best fashion items and
um you know the spend well beyond
Comfort on things like watches and and
uh and and cars and and and kind of to
kind of compensate I suppose for those
feelings of deficit that I had when I
was younger and for me when I say give
up a status possession what I'm really
saying is is is try to not to let your
status or your or your worth be defined
by things outside of yourself
so it might be really hard like to I
don't know put down the Rolex watch for
a moment and and go out with a Omega or
something you know whatever it might be
it might feel hard because you might
feel that that's going to Mark you in
some kind of negative way and what I'm
trying to say is to break down those
perfectionistic Tendencies it isn't just
about kind of putting yourself out there
embracing failure feeling set back some
of the rest of it but also letting go of
things that you think are uh external
markers of your self-worth and that can
be material possession certainly was for
me and that was one of the biggest you
know breakthroughs for me when I started
to let go not just of success is Affairs
but also things that I thought marked me
as a higher or lower status person and
so those possessions I think are you
know really important uh there's a
really famous quote I can't remember the
psychotherapist name now it's not coming
to my mind
um but you said whenever we are
excessive in our lives it is normally a
indication of some internal deprivation
and I think that's that's very true
certainly my experience that you know
being excessive with
material things was plugging a hole for
something that I was missing in myself
um so that's what I'm trying to get
across there yeah nice
um there's a good I think I either read
this in a happy by Darren Brown or in
William Irvine's Guide to the good life
which are both books about stoicism but
a good mental model of when it comes to
possessions which is
if there were no one else in the world
would I still want this thing
and obviously it's a somewhat flawed
like you know models if there was no one
else in the world then life might be
quite lonely uh but I think it does
speak to
a thing of am I buying this for the
signaling that it represents or am I
buying this thing because I actually
want this thing exactly now for a more
intrinsic reason
and I think that running things through
that filter
um at least for me
you know I'd still buy a book even if
like there was no one else in the world
because I want to read the book but
would I still buy a Canada Goose jacket
if there was no one else in the world
probably not like there's something
about having the logo on the shoulder
pad that feels feels good or and was
like interesting yeah and whenever I
like when I when I buy things I like to
run them through that filter
and if the answer is oh I probably won't
buy this if there was no one else in the
world that I at least think twice before
buying the thing because then I know
that like okay fundamentally I'm buying
this to Signal something to Signal some
sense of status or whatever
and that's not necessarily the worst
thing in the world but I think being
aware of it is is the first step yeah I
think like obviously you know high
profile individual like you know
millionaires of tick tock and people
like you know Andrew Tate who have kind
of Amplified these unrealistic
expectations of how one should you know
the good life I suppose
uh exactly like you said you know a lot
of peacocking a lot of very extravagant
spending to kind of Mark our status and
our worth in the world and I suppose you
know like you said it's look it yeah if
you want to buy nice things there's
nothing wrong with that like if it and
if it makes you feel good if there's
something about it that intrinsically uh
is fulfilling and gives you something in
your life there's nothing wrong with
that and if that happens to be a state
position then fine but it's it's why
you're buying it it's why you're trying
to Signal your worth in this way and I
think if you you know it can be it can
be exhausting and quite uh difficult for
our mental health if we continue trying
to upscale our lives and it goes back to
this idea that you know contentment
what we have meet ourselves where we are
those are the important things that's
the one
um what are your thoughts on social
media social media
I actually really think that social
media has such power to be a incredibly
useful tool in a disconnected World it
can bring people together around shared
interests it can facilitate offline
relations I have to say it can help with
meeting up uh groups it can help uh
bring diverse people together it can
help really solidify Community all of
these things by the way what it was
originally set up to do as a social
network in the truest sense of the world
so when Facebook first came out as a
university thing so it's to you know
kind of Grease the wheels of University
and campus life and credulous college
students like me used to use it to kind
of organize football socials or you know
set up a drinking circles or go you know
you know uh bring together different
types of communities within the
university around shared interests and
this is what it was used for you know it
really helped university community and
bring people together on campus but
unfortunately
it isn't that anymore and what it is is
an advertising device uh it's really
that's where the yes profits made and
and and so the imperative the social
media algorithms now are not to
facilitate offline relationships but to
keep people online
to keep them you know engaged with the
app scrolling through flicking through
pictures again
instilling a sense that you know that
you could be more there's these images
of other people's lives and Lifestyles
that appear very perfect and you could
have this
if only if only oh and here's a targeted
ad right when you're you're kind of you
most need ah and this is what I need to
buy in order to have this life and
lifestyle so social media has become
kind of an advertising device that
follows the traditional route of analog
advertising that kind of puts it on
steroids uh amplifies unrealistic ideals
so that targeted ads can can provide
material Solutions
and it ha and it's not a Social Network
anymore it's an advertising device and I
think that's where the damage can come
so social media per se is not a negative
thing
um it can it's got tremendous power to
be incredibly enlivening
but
at the moment
it has in my opinion this is this is
just my read of social media but my
opinion it's gearing itself towards
creating those kind of aspects of
discontent that are very cat-nip for
perfectionism catnip for advertisers
Keepers consuming Keepers working harder
to attain kind of life and Life Starts
projected as 24 7 in social media so my
opinion on social media is quite nuanced
I think it's got a lot of potential it's
got a lot of power but at the moment
it's the algorithms are designed in a
way that can create more discontent than
purpose hmm
so what are the strategies maybe around
social media for people who struggle
with perfectionism I think it's really
about learning what what social media is
first and foremost understanding that it
is an advertising device you know you
know Instagram Facebook Tick Tock
they're not they don't disguise this uh
they talk about how ad revenues are
really the revenue streams for the
platforms they're very open about it
um and it's just about understanding
that you know if we can approach social
media understanding that the way it
makes money is through advertising and
the way advertising works is that we are
you know kind of lured into a sense that
we need a product and so social media
works on this deficit model we can
understand that as a first step and then
the second step is to go back to what it
was originally for so engage with
Instagram but on interest that you know
important to you like build a community
around things that you know whether it
be pets or cooking or cycling or
whatever it might be use Instagram to
really facilitate those offline
relationships to meet people and spend
time in the world outside social media
with other people uh I think going back
to social media is its original purpose
is really really important and for young
people I think education is so crucial I
think if you're a parent it's really
important to educate young people in
what social media is about and how it
can be used positively
um in terms of build you know
facilitating offline relations
um so so for me it's just it's really
about engaging in it with it in the
right way it's not about getting rid of
it all together hmm yeah makes a lot of
sense I think one thing that I like to
do is
um you know I get a lot of value from
Twitter weirdly and people always are
surprised by that and you know whenever
I say to people oh yeah you know Twitter
is a great source of information and
insight and everything like but wait
what I thought Twitter was just for the
news and for like dunking on and rotate
or whatever
um but I think a lot of it is about
curating the people that you follow and
curating your feed so that it does give
you
great book recommendations and stuff
rather than kind of
vitriol or hate or like lifestyle
aspirationally type things yeah and so I
like to keep my feeds broadly
educational adjacent
um
with the occasional like
you know male fitness model to inspire
me to actually go to the gym
I find that like that level of
um kind of nudge towards from social
media it's like oh well you know if I
see a photo of a gym shark Athlete on
the thing I'll be like you know what I'm
gonna go gym today and I think that's
broadly a healthy thing even though
probably the reason behind it might be
like my body's not good enough yeah kind
of like you know there are there are
there are worse outcomes other than I'm
gonna go gym today
I mean look you know people use social
media in their own ways and I I think
I'm also a user at Twitter I think you
know the world we live in right now is
is one where
there's a lot of uh impetus to kind of
like you say Duncan people to kind of
um to for views for shares for likes for
mentions you know kind of extreme views
are Amplified and uh views are polarized
within those uh settings but like you
said if you can use it in a way that's
broadly positive you can follow the
right people you make sure that your
feed is
um managed so that you don't see too
much of this kind of scrap screeching
and noise then it's obviously a very
positive thing you keep up with the news
you can you know you can you can gain
Insight from influencers who you think
have some really valuable stuff to share
it's a positive experience but again
it's about managing that is is the
important part
um and understanding that you know
there's good things and bad things about
the pro about the platforms yeah
um okay something potentially
controversial that you say in the book
is that you don't believe in the growth
mindset what what do you mean you don't
believe in the growth mindset okay so I
really love this because you're the
first person to really challenge me on
this and I really want to have this
discussion because I think it's so
important and and a healthy debate on
these issues is really crucial I guess
it is a provocative part of the book and
maybe there's a bit uh a deliberate
provocation here but I do think we need
to have a conversation
and the reason why I think we have to
have a conversation is this one of the
things that troubles me a little bit
about the growth mindset and by the way
I'm not against growth I think growth is
absolutely fundamental to human
development but what I am against is the
sense that we have to grow at all times
so you'll often hear uh quotes like you
can't let you failures Define you you
have to let your failures teach you or
fail better as you'll often hear
sometimes in corporate speak
these these mantras uh sound Noble but
when you actually dig into them you find
something that's quite unhuman and I'm
focusing on this first part of that
quote this idea that you can't let your
failures Define you
because what that tells us at some level
is that there's something
deeply shameful about dwelling in a
state of failure that somehow that sense
of failure has to be immediately
rehabilitated on the Redemptive Arc of
growth or Excellence or development and
that it can't be left alone
to just sit for a moment
not touched not rehabilitated
not change not suppressed but just
allowed to be exist as it is as a kind
of humanizing as I mentioned earlier
humanizing part of our existence
that that failure
or setback or roadblock or thing that
didn't turn out the way we expected it
to turn out it's just part and parcel of
what it means to be a human
and so the reason why I wanted to push
back a little bit on the growth mindset
is that as a mindset I.E a mind that is
set on one thing that is growth
can be problematic when you string it
out over time and only allow yourself to
grow and not let in areas of life where
you might stand still or you might
regress and accept them as just kind of
natural normal parts of our existence so
that is why I'm pushing back a little
bit on the growth mindset because I
think growth is fine but sometimes you
won't always grow and that's also fine
okay that's very reasonable
I wouldn't I wouldn't uh disagree with
any of that
um so it sounds like you're
okay so growth mindset as distinct from
fixed mindset would be kind of how Carol
work would describe it growth mindset
being like our abilities are not fixed
and can grow fixed mindset our abilities
are fixed and therefore any failure is a
uh reduction of myself because like oh
it shows that I'm stupid it shows that I
have no software so in that sense going
kind of perfectionism falls into the
quote fixed mindset thing but I guess
what you're saying is growth mindset if
taken too far then could can also be
problematic like any vote you take into
excess becomes a vice exactly and
there's always a balance here between
self-improvement and self-acceptance and
not everything needs to be converted
into a kind of here are eight lessons I
learned on a Twitter thread
um for from any kind of setback
sometimes we can just be like accepting
of a failure and we can choose to
reframe it as growth if we want or we
can choose to be like yep that was a bad
day the office or if we're really
enlightened we can choose to not accept
it as part of the you know surrendering
to the flow of Life yeah um but we
shouldn't it sounds like what you're
saying is that we shouldn't feel as if
we have to convert every single failure
into some sort of lesson or some sort of
growth opportunity yeah yeah Karen uh
horny who's uh was a psychotherapist who
was probably one of the first to really
delve into perfectionism in any great
detail in the 30s 40s and 50s uh talked
about something called The Tyranny
issued and that's in this Society we
feel like we should be x y z should be
fit a stronger happier healthier more
productive and these and these
tyrannical shoulds are what create
divides within us
from the imperfect person we really are
you know the person's flaw that makes
mistakes that
um will sometimes slip up to the perfect
person that Society tells us we should
be you know strong fit healthy
attractive intelligent whatever it might
be productive whatever it might be
and my worry with the growth mindset is
is that what we're doing is we're just
kind of adding another should to a long
list of other shoulds that we should be
continually growing developing improving
and none of those things are problems
but I think Carl Rogers put it really
well when he said I am at my greatest
happiest when I strive towards scores to
which I am dimly aware
and I think that's a really interesting
way to look at life because yes we will
have goals yes we will have this kind of
ethereal Vision in our minds about where
we want to go so we might want to be you
know and uh you know a uh
a VP in our company we might want to be
a professor we might want to be a
YouTube influencer that has a massive
impact on vast waves of people you know
we have this kind of idea and image
where we want to go and yes you know on
the road there it's important to have
that kind of that kind of endpoint but
at the same time to know that not always
you're going to be you know always is it
going to be a case where you're going to
grow at the time like you're going to
hit you're going to hit roadblocks
you're going to go sideways you're going
to even regress sometimes because you
what you thought you knew you didn't
actually know
and all of these things are just as
important as growth you know feeling
like you're regressing isn't shameful it
isn't something to kind of quash or
avoid or not talk about or not think
about it's actually just part and parcel
of this kind of road to these goals that
you know in the in your mind's eye you
have a sense that this is where you want
to go but but you know tying yourself
and being fixed and having only kind of
a sense that you you you can only grow
on that journey I think is
for me anyway what's psychologically
challenging and can turn itself into
perfectionism if left unchecked so so
this is what I'm I guess this is the
point I'm trying to get across to this
idea that you know
growth growth growth is fine but too
much can be perfection
I love that yeah the tyranny of should
I've been I've I've been thinking a lot
about this a lot over the last few
months like
whenever I find myself uh sort of
giving myself a should I always kind of
like hmm interesting like well when I
tell myself oh I should go to the gym I
sort of have grown now to recognize they
should and really think Hmm
what's what's going on here and on what
level I should go to the gym because it
is good to be healthy and I Value Health
as uh you know all that crap on another
level it's a should and too many shoulds
uh lead to a shitty life as some people
might say yeah so that's really good
thank you it's not an original I wish
um do you
I I I've been unable to figure out like
I you know I like things to fit into
neat buckets and like I would love to be
able to say
telling yourself [__] is always a bad
thing uh but clearly it's not clearly
there's like a middle way um have you
have you got any thoughts on where is
the middle ground between uh
should versus like not should that make
sense I'd add another tyranny in today's
question the Tyranny I could
um because I think there's a tyranny
assured how we should look but then
there's always a tyranny of where we
could be and what we could have and who
we and you know uh particularly in a
meritocratic culture like ours we're
told all the time that you could be this
right supposedly uh meritocratic culture
uh supposedly married
uh one that valorizes meritocracy
doesn't necessarily follow it through
yeah
um but of course like but you know you
told you could be this if you just try
hard enough so not only are we do we
have these [__] should coming at us from
the bottom to say this is how you should
be also have these coulds from the top
going and you can also be this person
with kind of pincered
um in the middle uh I think you know I
don't think there's any coincidence that
Karen horny came to the conclusion at
the end of her writing that kind of Zen
Buddhism was the way forward
she kind of ended there and this is kind
of a big influence on my thinking too
because this kind of idea of Letting Go
living in the moment being present and
trying not to be overly impacted by the
ways in which you're told you should
behave and should look and all the rest
of it and could be is the is by far and
away the most Fail-Safe path to a
contented life yep
uh but you know
it's not easy there are practical things
we can do I've talked about some of them
but it's not easy I just think you know
even just being aware that these things
are pressing on us is the first step
um and so uh so yeah
that's uh that's my take
um I really like that thing you said as
well around like being being dimly aware
of goals yeah
um I I want one thing that I'm kind of
trying to attempting to make the case
for which is kind of annoying because
it's actually hard to find evidence for
this
um you know the whole like smart goal
stuff
um specific goals show a specific and
challenging goals correlate with
increased performance that's right and
that's kind of annoying because I've
always been antique specific and
challenging goals in that I prefer my
goals to be a bit more vague pencil
sketchy and I prefer them not to not
ideally be that challenging and I prefer
them to be within my control yeah like
oh I vaguely want to make one YouTube
video a week for the next two years and
let's see what happens and that was how
I stayed consistent on YouTube for two
years whereas everyone I know is like
I'm going to make x videos which will
hope where the specific measurable
challenging goal is 10 000 subscribers
those people realize that failure after
failure after failure you can't control
that outcome so like you end up just
burning out and giving up whereas if
it's a pencil sketch goal that's not
that challenging that's fully within
your control well
Potter that's a recipe for yeah good
contentment at least what do you know
what you'll be pleased to learn that
actually new research is coming forward
right now uh to kind of challenge that
idea of the specific goal framework
um and in particular Champion like you
just said more nebulous goals goals yeah
incredible where I can put some of those
into the book can you tell me more
um so so resurgical Christian Swan
um has done some work on goal setting I
can send you some papers actually it's
probably a bit faster for you that way
um and they're just showing that you
know it's not always about setting
specific Hardline goals that creates the
Maximum Impact that actually and this is
in sports setting because my background
in sports psychologist is what I Know
This research
um but then actually you know if you set
yourself less clear but nevertheless you
know
um pointed goals so you know like you
say these girls where you have an idea
if you can I want to
um you know win a race it doesn't have
to be like this specific race on this
specific day but like over the course of
a year I want to win X amount of races
it doesn't matter where or when or why
it just matters that you know you have
this kind of this goal that kind of is
pushing you in this direction
but nevertheless it's not a kind of
imperative that I must do this on this
time yeah and there's some really
interesting uh data that's coming
through to suggest actually you know
those types of goals are a lot more
psychologically freeing and actually
contribute to higher performance
interestingly enough than the more
specific goals so I'll send you that
research if you want I can't speak in
too much detail about because it's not
my area but I think you might find it
interesting yeah oh that sounds great
yeah I think I think about like the the
name actually rings a bell I think I've
come across some of this stuff in my
zotero library when I've been looking
into this but one one phrase that like I
really
and I I haven't heard anyone's phrase
the phrase it this way but I'm sure
someone would have done way before me is
that
goals are a destiny oh sorry goals are a
direction they're not a destination
and setting a goal of like pencil
sketching a rough Direction means okay
cool I'm gonna sit on this journey and
try my best to enjoy every step of the
every step of the process because you
know as Miley Cyrus would even say it's
it's the climb it's not about it's not
about how fast I get there ain't about
what's waiting on the other side it's
the climb I think it's really important
also to remember that it depends who's
doing these things so for some people
like read your goals are not not a bad
thing like if you're conscientious and
you make a list of things that you want
to achieve well that is actually quite
useful because it gives you a kind of
road map that you can apply your
energies towards but if you're
perfectionistic you're not setting those
strict and rigid goals because they're
kind of a roadmap you're setting them
because they're managing your anxiety
they're like I need to set these goals
because if I don't set them and I don't
meet them then my anxiety is going to go
through the roof so this is kind of a
way of managing anxiety that we're
saying is God so I think again it goes
back to where it comes from and the
reason why we're setting these things in
the first place and if you're especially
perfectionistic having rigid firm and
what are often lofty goals is going to
be really problematic because you may
not meet them and you may not mean them
for you know no good reason yeah you
could just have a bad day you know you
could have woken up on the wrong side of
the bed a global pandemic could have
come and shattered the the project that
you were working on completely out of
your control for the pet section is
that's really tough psychologically for
the conscientious person it's not so bad
they set the goal they move towards it
they didn't quite meet it they can
accept that so again it just also
depends on personalities too yeah
absolutely
um one of the method models I use for
this is sort of imagining like
lowering the bar and if you struggle
with procrastination keep the bar as low
as humanly possible if you're struggling
with consistency keep the bar really
really low yeah and by a low bar I mean
uh vaguely defined uh not particularly
lofty and optically ambitious goal but
then as you clear that bar you raise the
bar slightly and then you raise it
slightly and you raise it slightly
exactly so for an Olympic gymnast the
bar of oh I'm just going to show up to
practice whenever I feel like it it's
probably not that helpful they won't win
which is fair enough yeah but for
someone who struggles to go to the gym
you know setting a lofty goal of
becoming Mr Olympia is probably actually
going to cause you to procrastinate
rather than help you avoid that and so
kind of adjusting adjusting the height
of the bar
lowering lowering it to make it vague
and like not that lofty right exactly
right and I tell this machines all the
time because lots of them I really
struggled to start essays right because
this is like a they see eyes of three
thousand what they say this is really
like oh my God I'm not gonna do very
well in this test it's really hard topic
I don't know about it ah so let's go on
Netflix
um I just say just get just just write
something write a letter to your mum
like just look at words on a on a on a
on a computer screen and start the
process it doesn't even have to be
related to the task at hand because if
you can start writing from it's a nice
note to your mum but also it gets you in
that kind of frame of mind where you're
putting words on paper and then begin
and then you know like you say it
doesn't have to be uh you don't even
have to consult the literature just put
down your thoughts on this particular
topic right and then begin to iterate
work those thoughts into some kind of
structure then bring in the literature
and build it like build it uh from you
know piece by piece
um because that is a way better way of
Smashing through the procrastination
than going everything has to be perfect
right now on the first draft and if it
isn't I can't possibly do it so what
you're saying there is a really really
helpful way for people to break through
that procrastination because I know
procrastination is something that a lot
of people struggle with yeah yeah
um there's a quote from uh Cal Newport
that I love for this which is you know
he says that when he's right when when
he's working on his books
he tells it he he tells himself every
time this one just needs to be
reasonable the next one is going to be
good yeah and so I'm trying to take that
attitude towards everything in my life
whether it's book writing or like a gym
workout or a YouTube video this one just
needs to be reasonable the next one's
gonna be good and I get to that one it's
like this one just needs to be
reasonable and I think reasonable or
good enough is I think the the solution
to a lot of the perfectionism
procrastination stuff that we deal with
and would you say like that's how you've
built up this channel right like do you
feel like it started there was a lot of
mistakes made at the beginning and you
can look back at it now and see the
development is that is that how you've
approached building up oh absolutely I
wouldn't even consider the mistakes I
would just be like yeah it was good
enough yeah as long as and and my bar
for a video is as long or a podcast
episode is as long as this helps at
least one person or has the potential to
help at least one person it's worth
putting out there that's a very low bar
and it's that's still the bar so you
know it's it's nice to be able to have
continued this for six years now great
well I mean it's really nice to see this
you've done really well I mean some of
the numbers you get are incredible so
and it's growing right
yeah it's good no it's really it's
really obviously it works whatever
you're doing it works another one well
Thomas thank you so much for coming on
this has been absolutely wonderful any
final pieces of parting wisdom for those
who might have gotten to the end of this
episode who are still struggling with
perfectionism uh okay well
three words I suppose you are enough and
that is all that is what it is to be a
human being You Are a Human Being you
exist so you are enough and I think
that's the most important lesson to take
through life something to remember all
the time when things go well things
don't go quite so well it's okay you're
human we fail you are enough beautiful
thank you so much no worries all right
so that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye